salut tout le monde je fais une petite
annonce en vidéo alors c'est pas c'est
un truc que j'ai pas l'habitude de faire
parce que normalement j'utilise plutôt
le site ou le facebook he je vais faire
des annonces mais là comme c'est
vraiment des annonces qui concernent
vraiment tous les gens qui regardent les
vidéos ben je préfère la faire en vidéo
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
vont pas sur le site ou sur le facebook
donc ben la première annonce c'est pas
de vidéo en septembre en fait on revient
en début octobre pour la prochaine vidéo
pour une raison simple ben vous le voyez
derrière moi il y a plein de cartons
c'est qu'en fait ben je déménage c'est
aussi du coup hein et euh donc le temps
qu'on soit opérationnel de nouveau vu
qu'on déménage début septembre on sera
opérationnel à mon avis entre le 10 et
le 15 de nouveau doncs de poser les
meubles de monter les meubles et cetera
de faire les démarche donc la prochaine
vidéo on content que ça fait 3 semaines
de production ça sera début octobre par
contre entre-temps alors ça sera entre
le 10 et le 15 septembre je pense il y
aura la première vidéo du second concept
dont j'ai parlé sur le site pour ceux
qui suivent les news du site qui
s'appelle papic grenier donc ce concept
ce sont des vidéos humoristiques qui
sont beaucoup plus courtes qui font 5
minutes environ euh c'est pas des tests
commejourd'h grenier réellement c'est
vraiment de l'humour vraiment du délire
euh sans test et donc ce qui nous
permettra de parler de bons jeux aussi
justement et ça c'est cool ça va nous
permettre de de jouer à des bons jeux et
ça c'est bien et euh donc ce ce premier
épisode de ce second concept donc
arrivera entre le 10 et le 15 en fait le
but à terme euh quand on aura repris
notre vitesse de croisière près le
déménagement dans quelques mois donc euh
à terme donc c'est euh qu'on puisse euh
faire un épisode de Joueur du Grenier
euh par mois plus un épisode de papier
grenier ce qui fait qu'il y aura deux
épisodes par mois donc le l'épisode
habituel de jour du grenier plus donc ce
ce second épisode donc voilà ben c'est
tout ce que j'ai à dire donc rendez-vous
en septembre pour la prochaine vidéo et
puis avant que vous partiez ne fin ne
terminez pas la vidéo tout de suite
annonce d'intérêt général vous pensiez
que ACTA était mort que vous aviez gagné
mais dans les films les méchants
reviennent toujours deux
fois les zombies de sont ici négoci en
secret pendant que personne ne regarde
il s'appelle alors signez les pétitions
et qu'on arrête s'il vous plaît de nous
prendre pour des con